this was the suspect trying to break
into a charity home and being shoved off
an hour earlier he had stabbed two
students to death minutes later he
stabbed a third victim stole his van and
mowed down three pedestrians
a charity trustee said residents had a
lucky Escape an event like this can
definitely turn people's feelings up
especially when they're already kind of
affordable people that are healthier so
yeah and and was that was anyone harmed
or anything uh there was Noah from our
residents quite shaken uh yes
emotionally people
it's a suspect ever said here why did he
come here that we're not sure but he
hasn't said here
so your your clueless as to why he chose
to come here correct yeah
suspect to 31 year old man was still
being questioned as the investigation
continued here police finishing a search
of what's thought to be the suspect's
former home police were called at four
minutes past four on Tuesday morning
they found students Barnaby Weber and
Grace O'Malley Kumar unresponsive in
ilkeston Road
police said a man matching the suspect's
description tried to get into a home in
Napoli road but failed
the suspect is then thought to have
stabbed Ian Coates on magdala road and
stolen his van
within minutes the van was used to run
down three people on Milton Street
a man is critical in hospital the other
two have minor injuries
soon after police say the suspect
abandoned the van and confronted
officers with a knife he was tasered and
arrested
they are currently leaving an open mind
as to the motives Behind these attacks
attack but I can confirm Nottinghamshire
police are being assisted in their
inquiries by counter-terror police
though this does not mean that it is
currently being treated as a terrorist
attack
on the road where the students died the
crime scene investigation was over as
police began a cleanup
we now know that Grace ran from her
attacker into the front garden of this
house and tried to get help but nobody
was home that night and Grace died on
the doorstep the woman who lives here
told us she was heartbroken maybe she
said we could have saved her
please have until Saturday morning to
question their suspect before they must
charge or release him
not in brunt Sky News Nottingham